if you were watching the convention last
night you probably watching now from
your panic room if did you see wow did
you see Donald Trump speech if that
features any darker we'd be shot by the
police
it made me nostalgic for the
light-hearted remarks of Rudy Giuliani
he used the word violence a dozen times
murder half a dozen times and that was
just the part about Ted Cruz I tell you
it was home oh it was a rough Street and
another another plagiarism scandal yeah
oh yeah now turns out Trump stole his
speech too from a Saw movie partly
Herrmann will be and partly from Glenn
Beck having a breakdown
he put those together and if you didn't
see it to recap okay it's morning in
America where the walls are streaked
with blood uh we're a shining city on a
hill which is where we will make our
last stand against the zombies and Isis
and illegal immigrants are coming to
kill us all unfortunately there's no one
to save us because Hillary wiped out the
police with her email so that's that's
pretty much the state of America oh yes
it's bleak out there bleep oh and who
could save us who who who is there one
man who code X right Donald Trump that's
right in fact we have a picture of his
new campaign poster
now we have had 30 years to get used to
Donald Trump's ego even I was not ready
when he started to tick off every awful
thing that's going on in the world and
then said the words I alone can fix it
move over Jesus there's a new savior in
town that's right only he only Donald
Trump can stop Mexicans from raping us
and setting our corpses on fire really I
can't even get the valet Parker guys to
stop changing the radio station
I don't know now Donald Trump said the
crime and violence that afflicts our
nation will soon come to an end January
20th 2017 safety will be restored oh
[ __ ] he thinks he's Batman now he he's
gonna restore her safety vanquish crime
at n violence and then he's gonna
capture all the Pokemon so it's gonna
really really work out well for
everything now as to the question of how
he's going to do all this do not
question Zod
zero specifics not the slightest hint of
how he's gonna fix anything nothing even
James Bond villains when they tie you up
tell you they're playing a little but
but that's Donald Trump you know he's a
doer not a talker any politician can
talk about unemployment he actually
showed us Scott Baio
and of course luckily for him his
daughter Ivanka you saw that less she
came on before him to soften his image
she said her father was colorblind and
gender-neutral well that explains his
makeup now what about what about policy
but okay but I do have news about an
hour ago we found out Hillary has picked
Tim Kaine as her vice presidential
candidate exactly the only man who could
possibly match the raw animal magnetism
of Mike Pence no actually Tim Kaine a
smart choice a lot of experience helps
her win Virginia and most importantly
knows how to set up an email server
you